le journal de l'Afrique en direct du
studio Jean Karim Fall à Paris soyez les
bienvenus sur France 24 à la une ce soir
la Cour constitutionnelle sous pression
à Centrafrique elle doit statuer sur une
requête déposée par une plateforme de
l'opposition le bloc républicain de la
défense de la Constitution et il se
dresse contre le décret présidentiel
créant une commission de rédaction d'une
nouvelle constitution dans le pays nous
en parlerons avec notre invité Thierry
virkoulon chercheur associé à l'IFRI la
Côte d'Ivoire rappelle en urgence à un
sommet de la CEDEAO le pays conteste les
exigences du Mali pour la libération de
ses 46 soldats détenus à Bamako Bamako
qui souhaitent les échanger contre des
personnalités politiques maliennes en
exiles en Côte d'Ivoire nous serons à
Abidjan dans ce journal
et à la fin de ce journal nous irons au
Cameroun la capitale souffre de pénurie
d'eau ses habitants vivent un calvaire
entre remplissage et achat d'eau potable
reportage à suivre à la fin de cette
édition
d'ici à la fin du mois la Cour
constitutionnelle centrafricaine va
devoir rendre une décision très attendue
elle va devoir statuer sur le décret
présidentiel créant une commission de
rédaction d'une nouvelle constitution
dans le pays le bloc républicain pour la
défense de la Constitution une
plateforme de l'opposition a déposé un
recours depuis les juges de la Cour sont
sous pression pour en parler nous
recevons Thierry virkoulon chercheur
associé à literie et spécialiste des
Grands Lacs merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau alors tout d'abord
le président toit d'Era propose donc une
nouvelle constitution on aimerait savoir
pourquoi que comporte-t-elle et que
cherche-t-il exactement pour le moment
il
mène une campagne pour la rédaction
d'une nouvelle constitution et comme
vous le disiez il a nommé un comité qui
doit rédiger cette nouvelle Constitution
et l'objectif qui semble assez évident
et celui d'obtenir un troisième
puisqu'il en est à son deuxième mandat
et que la Constitution actuelle limite
le nombre de mandats à deux et donc il
devrait partir à la prochaine séance
électorale or depuis le printemps de
cette année on a vu qu'il a lancé cette
initiative et donc beaucoup de
d'observateurs et de centres africains
considèrent que son intention est en
effet de pouvoir prolonger son pouvoir
alors comment
le
processus tel qu'il est défini
actuellement a commencé au mois de mai
ou un projet de loi a été adopté par le
l'Assemblée nationale qui soutenait
l'idée de cette révision
constitutionnelle et donc après le feu
vert de l'Assemblée nationale le
président a nommé a pris un décret noms
ce comité à la fin du mois de mai ce
comité doit rédiger un projet de
nouvelles Constitution qui serait
proposée par référendum à la population
centrafricaine alors la
on va parler de ce référendum rapidement
est-ce que les conditions sont réunies
pour un tel référendum il y a déjà eu un
référendum constitutionnel en 2015 et
donc qui a accouché en quelque sorte de
la Constitution actuelle et donc on peut
considérer que actuellement les
conditions sont bien meilleures en
Centrafrique pour organiser un
référendum que elle ne l'était en 2015
ou là les groupes armés dominés
véritablement le pays alors je le disais
tout à l'heure le Conseil
constitutionnel et les juges en tout cas
subissent une pression forte
ont-ils les coûts des franges pour
rendre une décision par rapport à cette
nouvelle Constitution sont-ils libres
sont-ils disposés à le faire ils doivent
rendre leur verdict dans à la fin du
mois oui on a vu en ce mois de septembre
un certain nombre de manifestations
devant la Cour constitutionnelle de
militants protoadera et des actes
d'intimidation à l'égard des juges
constitutionnels et du coup il y a eu
des contre-réactions notamment des
avocats qui a décidé de se mobiliser
pour défendre la liberté de travail et
de conscience des juges constitutionnels
et donc il a voulu manifester aussi où
je séjours a été interdit etc donc on
sent qu'il y a une vraie crispation une
vraie mobilisation des deux camps pro et
anti-révisions constitutionnelles et que
en fait la bataille juridique autour de
cette révision constitutionnelle ne fait
que commencer
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui en
Centrafrique la situation politique dans
un premier temps et sécuritaire au plan
politique on a une Assemblée nationale
qui est largement dominée par le parti
au pouvoir et une opposition qui a été
très fortement marginalisée depuis les
élections 2020 et qui a été aussi
intimidé à de nombreuses reprises et qui
considèrent que la Russie
soutient fortement le président toit des
rats et que le jeu politique est assez
faussé actuellement à Bangui un certain
nombre d'opposants ont quitté le pays à
un moment après ils sont revenus ils ont
quitté pour des raisons de sécurité et
donc certains sont revenus et on a
observé une détente lorsqu'il y a eu un
peu le dialogue républicain mais
maintenant avec le lancement de ce
processus de révision constitutionnel on
a de nouveau une crispation politique
après au plan sécurité on peut dire que
la situation est assez stationnaire dans
les provinces
où le gouvernement a repris le contrôle
de la plupart des villes importantes en
tout cas et où les groupes armés sont
maintenant limités aux zones rurales où
ils font de temps en temps quelques
attaques il y en a eu dernièrement une
sur la la préfecture de Bria mais ça
reste des attaques assez sporadiques et
de faible importance pour le moment où
il faut aussi savoir que on est en
saison des pluies en Centrafrique et que
par conséquent ce n'est pas un moment
qui est favorable pour pour des
offensives commentaires alors très
rapidement est-ce que on peut comparer
la l'influence russe en Centrafrique à
celle qui existe au Mali aujourd'hui
dont on parle beaucoup
on peut en tout cas estimer que c'est un
peu le même template la même stratégie
qui est appliquée par la Russie où vous
avez à la fois une stratégie de
fourniture de soutien militaire de
soutien sécurité et en même temps de
conseils politiques merci beaucoup merci
pour votre expertise je rappelle que
vous êtes Thierry virkoulon chercheur
associé à livrer et spécialiste de
l'Afrique et des Grands Lacs merci
beaucoup pour votre expertise sur la
Centrafrique la Côte d'Ivoire qui
appelle à un sommet de la CEDEAO dans
les plus brefs délais les autorités
ivoiriennes souhaitent aborder en
urgence la question de ces 46 soldats
détenus à Bamako la Côte d'Ivoire qui a
pour la première fois réagit
officiellement aux exigences de Bamako
le Mali a fait savoir qu'il libérerait
les soldats ivoiriens en échange
d'extradition de personnalités malienne
exilé en Côte d'Ivoire la correspondance
à Abidjan de sa diamant Joe
la Côte d'Ivoire espérer la libération
des 46 soldats toujours détenu au Mali
mais Bamako on a décidé autrement si la
Côte d'Ivoire veut récupérer ses soldats
elle doit en retour leur livrer des
personnalités politiques maliennes mis
sous mandat d'arrêt international et
pourtant hébergé par Abidjan ce mercredi
réuni en conseil de sécurité
extraordinaire les autorités ivoiriennes
dénoncent un chantage inacceptable pour
eux en demandant cet échange Bamako
reconnaît que les soldats n'étaient pas
des mercenaires comme il le calme depuis
deux mois mais bien des soldats qui
prennent en otage au nom de la paix et
de la stabilité dans la région ils
appellent les chefs d'État des pays
d'Afrique de l'Ouest à se réunir au plus
vite pour trouver une solution pour
libérer les soldats
cette réunion pourrait bien se tenir à
New York la semaine prochaine en mars de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
la question est maintenant de savoir si
une issue diplomatique sera trouvée ou
si les pays de la CEDEAO prendront une
fonction contre le Mali
on en vient à ce verre dicte au Burkina
Faso dans l'affaire du drame de la mine
inondée de percoa qui a coûté la vie à 8
mineurs le tribunal de grande instance
de Koudougou a condamné le directeur de
la mine à 24 mois de prison avec sursis
il a été reconnu coupable pour homicide
involontaire il doit également
s'acquitter d'une amende de 2 millions
de francs Cfa les détails de notre
envoyé spécial à Ouagadougou ange no man
you
c'est la fin de procès qui aura duré un
six jours le directeur général de la
mine de percoa nfree a été reconnu
coupable d'homicide involontaire et doit
purger la peine de 24 mois de prison
avec sursis plus 2 millions de francs
Cfa d'amende il était poursuivi par le
tribunal de Ouagadougou pour avoir un
violet les règlements relatifs à la
sécurité et à la santé au travail dans
les mines et carrières non assistance à
personne en danger et mise en danger à
la personne d'autrui le porte-parole des
familles des victimes a bien accueilli
le verdict une arme denisation leur sur
un verset du côté de la Défense le
verdict a également été bien accueilli
ils disent avoir bien compris la
décision le 16 avril 2022 huit
travailleurs de la mine de percoa
c'était retrouvé coincé après de 720
mètres sous terre suite à une inondation
c'est un événement qui a créé un
sentiment à d'émotion dans tout le pays
qui espérait que les 8 mineurs soient
sauvés mais après plus de deux mois et
plusieurs opérations de sauvetage leur
corps a été retrouvé sans vie
le Niger sous pression migratoire a tenu
une rencontre internationale sur les
voies de la migration la semaine
dernière 50 migrants ont été secourus en
plein désert par les autorités
nigériennes alors qu'ils étaient en
route vers la Libye plusieurs centaines
d'autres avaient été renvoyés par la
frontière algérienne vers Agadez le
point avec notre correspondant à rôle
Girard
c'est l'organisation internationale pour
les migrations l'OIM qui a secouru
plusieurs dizaines de personnes en plein
désert nigériens la plupart revenait de
Libye certains étaient en direction de
ce pays qui a vu ces derniers mois ces
tensions internes se ravivent la
stabilité de la région nigérienne
frontalière de la Libye Agadez et
directement lié à l'évolution de la
situation sécurité de l'autre côté de la
frontière les flux migratoires qui
proviennent de pays plus au Sud en
Afrique passe par Agadez avant de
rejoindre la Libye et espérer gagner
l'Europe c'est donc un équilibre fragile
qui essaie de conserver le Niger un
équilibre qui ne pourra pas durer tant
qu’une entente régionale forte n’est pas
mise en place par les pays frontaliers
du Niger bon il faut déjà que que les
États parlent du même voie par rapport
aussi au pays de destination parce que
nous savons que c'est parce que aussi la
migration
en fait les frontières saufment de plus
en plus surtout pour les Africains les
jeunes qui veulent aussi explorer
d'autres opportunités que ce soit en
euros pour ailleurs se font face à des
contraintes alors que les jeunes
d'ailleurs peuvent venir facilement
s'installer au Niger au Sénégal et dans
tous nos pays sans aucune contre et cela
aussi encourage les voies détournées et
cela aussi encourage des trafiquants
donc je pense que il faut une opération
renforcée dans des pays du Nord et des
pays du Sud pour comprendre les enjeux
de la migration le Yem avait déjà
secouru en juillet dernier 51 personnes
dans ce même désert mais les flux les
plus importants de migrants qui
reviennent sur le territoire nigérien et
bien sont en provenance de la frontière
algérienne ou ces derniers mois
plusieurs milliers de subsahariens ont
été refoulés
apercevoir de l'eau sortir d'un robinet
relève presque du Mirage les coupures
d'eau sont de plus en plus récurrentes
et quand l'eau revient elle est colorée
et odorante du coup les habitants de la
capitale Camerounais sont obligés
d'avoir un budget pour l'eau potable
quand ils ne sont pas amenés à faire la
chasse à l'or bleu avec leur bidon
reportage au Cameroun de nos
correspondants Tony Menga et Michel
Mwando
c'est la même bataille depuis plusieurs
semaines le même combat quotidien
trouver de l'eau potable un précieux
liquide devenu rare pour les 3 millions
d'habitants de Yaoundé
[Applaudissements]
parce que les robinets sont à sec dans
leur maison ces riverains se bousculent
autour du seul point d'eau du quartier
une pénurie qui dure depuis des semaines
un calvaire pour Florent ça fait environ
4 heures de temps que je suis là c'est
vraiment pénible le gouvernement doit
penser à son peuple on ne peut pas
mourir de famine et mourir de soif en
même temps dans le quartier voisin la
même colère le même abattement chez
Ernesto dont les robinets tournent
désespérément dans le vide dans son
salon un amas de bidon vide des
récipients où il stockent ces dernières
rations d’eau de l'eau de pluie ou de
l'eau achetée au prix fort chez ses
voisins qui disposent de leur propre
voix
conditions du robinet même quand même
quand ça coule vous n'avez pas le
courage de boire c'est tout du coup la
plupart des familles sont obligées
d'avoir un budget d'eau un budget où
vous achetez une bonbonne comme celle-ci
minéral c'est cool 1000 francs un
véhicule 5 € le bidon d'eau un luxe que
le peut s'offrir de nombreuses familles
de quoi alimenter la colère des
populations
relayée à la une des nombreuses journaux
pointés du doigt le gouvernement tente
de trouver une parade le ministre de
l'eau fait le tour de cette station de
traitement dans le volume de production
a baissé de près de 40%. cette session
qui produisait 130
000 m3 par jour est déjà descendu à 80
000 mètres cubes par jour pour pouvoir
augmenter ses volumes d'eau il faudrait
un peu plus de produits pour le
traitement manque de produits du
traitement coupure d'électricité
chronique démographique galopante un
cocktail explosif qui fait baisser la
production épouse chaque jour des
milliers d'habitants de la capitale
camerounaise à se battre pour quelques
gouttes d'eau
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de Paris direct avec
Audrey racine
[Musique]